هذا ونقل مراسل الجزيره في الفانتاغون عن
مسؤول الدفاعيا امريكي قولها من القرار
اتخذ بتزويد اوكرانيا بذخيره اليورانيوم
بالمنظم الان كي تكون جاهزه للاستخدام متى
مات سلمت كياف دبابات وهو امر متوقع في
الخريف المقبل لكن الموعد النهائيه لم
يحدد بعد
لمتابعه هذا الملف مع من موسكو مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين نور الدين اذا واضحا
لديه رد فعل متعلق بتزويد واشنطن
المنظم ابرز ما لديك فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الروسي وكيف يتفاعل اذا هذا الدعم
[تصفيق]
منذ زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بلينكن
لكي ربما هنا لم يكن هناك ارتياح واضح لدى
الجانب الروسي ويعلم انه ربما هناك قد
تكون نوع من التحركات ذات البعد العسكري
بتقديم المزيد من الدعم لكن الحديث عن
تزويد اوكرانيا باليورانيوم المنظم ربما
هذا دفع الجانب الروسي الى رسم مجموعه من
المواقف التي تحدد طبيعه التعاطر مع هذا
الموضوع يبدو ان المبدا الاول الذي تتعامل
معه روسيا هو تحديد طبيعه هذا النوع من
السلاح وهو اليورانيم المنظم وماذا تاثيره
سواء على مستوى البيئه وعلى مستوى الوضع
الانساني عند استعمال هذا النوع من
الاسلحه وهو ما تحدثت به المتحدثه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه زخرفه لتقول وتعطي وتعطي
توصيفا واضحا لان لان هذا النوع من
الاسلحه هو الاسلحه المدمره للبيئه ربما
يدخل ضمن الاسلحه التي يحذر استعمالها
باعتبار تاثيرها على الوضع الانساني وربما
كذلك اكثر من ذلك نقل الامراض واعطاء
امثله سواء في حرب كوسوفو او في الحرب
التي شنتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
على العراق واثارات استعمال هذا النوع من
الاسلحه لذلك هناك توصيف قانوني بعد ذلك
تتحدث عنه روسيا هناك مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الروسي الروسي الذي وصف بان تزويد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاوكرانيا
بهذا النوع من الاسلحه يعتبر اجراما
باعتبار انه يخالف كل معايير العمل
العسكري باستعمال اسلحه ربما قد تكون
مخالفه للقانون الدولي وقد تؤثر بشكل كبير
على الوضع البيئي في المنطقه على الوضع
الانساني في المنطقه لذلك الان هناك موقف
ينبني على جزئين الجزء الذي يقتضي بتحريم
استعمال هذه الاسلحه وماذا تاثيرها على
المدى البعيد النقطه الثاني التوصيف
القانوني بوصفها مساله اجراميه لكن على
مستوى المعطى العسكري هنا الحديث الروسي
يقول بان اي اسلحه تصل الى اوكرانيا لن
تغير من طبيعه المواجهات لن تغير من طبيعه
الجبهات القائمه على الحرب بين روسيا وما
بين اوكرانيا ربما كان هناك الكثير من
الاسلحه التي تسلمتها اوكرانيا سواء
الدفاعات الجويه سواء مسيرات او صواريخ
لكن تقول روسيا ان هذا النوع من الاسلحه
لن ينهي الحرب ولن يعطي لاوكرانيا قدم
السبق على مستوى الجبهات في القتال لكن كل
هذا النوع من الاسلحه ماله الرئيسي هو
اطاله امد الحرب وربما القضاء على اي عوده
الى طاوله المفاوضات والحوار السياسي لذلك
هنا الحديث الروسي واضح بشكل واضح سواء ما
تحدثت به مندوبيه روسيا او سفاره روسيا
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما تحدثت به
وزاره الخارجيه ما تحدث به الدومه الروسي
بان هذا النوع من التعامل ربما هو اجرام
لكن بكل تاكيد لن يغير مسار الحرب مسار
الحرب تحدده طبيعه الجبهات ومدى حضور
القوات وربما اكثر من ذلك هناك حديث عسكري
بان هذا التزويد المتواصل لاوكرانيا
بالاسلحه ربما قد يغير طبيعه الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه لروسيا كما نعلم على انه منذ
فتره طويله ربما قد تصل الى اكثر من سته
اشهر طبيعه العمل العسكري الروسي انتقل من
طبيعه الحاله الهجوميه الى الحاله
الدفاعيه واقامه حواجز سد لمنع اي تقدم
للقوات الاوكرانيه والحفاظ على ما تم
الحصول عليه خلال السنه ونصف من عمر الحرب
ما بين روسيا وما بين اوكرانيا لكن الحديث
عن تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه متقدمه ربما قد
يدفع الجانب الروسي الى تغيير طبيعه الحرب
من حاله الدفاع الى حاله الهجوم وهذا ما
يراج الان هناك هنا عسكريا ما بين الاوساط
العسكريه بان استراتيجيه روسيا ربما قد
تتغير خلال الشهر او شهرين القادمين في
حربها مع اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك